why do you think Florida is so far
behind I mean I mean how many state
there's seven states is that right right
now that are legal for recreational
correct so why I mean when do you think
this will happen with Florida why's
Florida so far behind Florida has
listened Florida really has had a couple
of different challenges the first
challenge being the governor right a
Governor Rick Scott and the initial
understanding that there's another
gentleman named Nelson blur of some was
a billionaire he lives right here in
Pinellas County really he is actually
the one that supported Ric for both his
first run as governor in the second run
okay yeah I know who he is real estate
guy
bingo yeah he's also a big nor cam guy
he used to own and have a business back
in the 80s called straight was a drug
intervention program he is now another
one I can't I don't promote his website
but it's a it's a it's like drug free
America calm and it's so he's really
against it so he's big-time against and
he was a big supporter of Rick Scott
absolutely and also a big big supporter
of narcan and some of the other drugs
that are fair our cameras obviously you
guys know that if you take an overdose
of heroin and to show you with it bring
it back bring it back alive it's
obviously it be whose him to have
cannabis not legal so the people will
continue this madness with the fentanyl
and all the other drugs out here that
are killing people left and right
it got so ridiculous to Jesus Christ
it's ridiculous man if you look at
Manatee County here in Florida last year
I think it isn't it may be off on my
year but they were typically having
about one to four overdoses a month it
went to one to four overdoses a day and
they had to open up a second morgue
where is this this is a manatee County
just south of where we're located at and
what was the overdoses were they
overdosing on
most of it was fentanyl okay heroin be
so pure they would actually do it in
like you know the with the kids in the
back in the gas station and then yeah we
could take a picture of them all passed
out in the truck hanging out all over
the place so it behooves him
and when I say him Nelson blur for I not
have cannabis legal in the state of
Florida so what happened then I'm sure
I'm sure this is the business deal
between those guys kind of went like hey
if you do this for me I'll do this for
you and make sure you get you know you
have all the money you need to get voted
in to be the next senator
and so that he put a gentleman in place
by the name of Christian Bock who were
in the Department of Health the
Department of Health which is kind of
odd or the group that actually handled
the cannabis here in Florida when it
should be the department agriculture and
but he did that again to set it up
purposely so that they would run
interference on the legalization of it
so that what they did was they put
different processes in place to slow it
down in other words you couldn't smoke
flour it had to be into an oil type
right um like a vaping pen of some sort
right they made sure that there was no
edibles you had to process it you had to
do what's called vertical integration
you had to do everything right there at
the grow from grow it to process it you
had to provide your own security your
own transportation
and at the end of the day these
nurseries that were selected or selected
because of their ability to produce a
quality plant not to do security work
not to do processing so this slowed
everything down because now the
nurseries got to learn how to process
they have to understand transportation
mm-hm they need to understand there's an
expense involved with that so as the the
kind of the the program went along it
just kind of got slower and slower
because guys didn't know how to process
now they're gonna know do that now with
Governor De Santis in place who
understands the will of the people here
in Florida again let's not forget 72
percent of the people here in vote for
to voted for medical cannabis that the
will of the people was to be able to
smoke flower so they'll now be able to
have up to two ounces of cannabis in
their possession this is still have to
be finalized and through through the
Senate but they'll be able to have two
ounces of cannabis in their possession
and I listen don't travel with it in
your car yeah let's not smoke it in the
car you will get caught and it's a bad
day right now law enforcement of taken a
different look at this yeah again we
have to understand this is about
generating revenue the Sheriff's
Department's our business they have to
be run like a business right
the majority of law enforcement
officials from the Chiefs to the actual
sheriff's I've spoken to all believe
that it should be recreational available
the problem is that it generates money
for them for every the way was put to me
was that they might most marijuana
smokers or easy targets I get reimbursed
from the federal government for
everybody I arrest so really what you're
asking me to do is give up part of my
budget which have oh by the way here in
Florida taken a beating since 2008 so
now you just ask me to give up more of
that money it's not it's listen it's a
victimless crime you know people don't
smoke pot and attack my deputies we talk
to our narcotics guys I'll talk to all
the guys across the board they all
realize where we're going with this and
what should happen I tell you if you put
somebody in prison who has smoked
cannabis they don't come out a better
person at the end of the day